why do these serial killers open up to
you at all
why why you well interesting question I
think if we come away from serial
killers we go to John Kernan who
murdered Shirley banks in Bristol
definitely the Suzy lamb clue and
certainly Sandra courting Bournemouth to
give you an idea when his case when he
was finally locked up for life I I wrote
to him to say that I wanted to write a
book about him and he came back very
cocky and said oh well now I've got I've
got dozens of authors and publishers
want my exclusive story so then I got
John Blake my publisher that sort of
send me some pictures of my book covers
and I sent him those with a letter
saying well thanks very much I really
wanted your assistance I think you've
been stitched up by the police John I'll
write the story without your cooperation
thanks a lot so I put it between a rock
and a hard place
and I try to use the same fishing
techniques with women and male serial
killers in finding out what their wants
and their needs are it's like beach
fishing you know where the fish swim
like Robinson you know what he wants but
it's a case of casting the right bait to
catch him
with Melanie McGuire's in that book the
ice queen she was in New Jersey upscale
woman good lifestyle chopped up a
husband threw him in bits and pieces in
the Chesapeake Bay but but but she had
hundreds of letters and publishers
wanting her so I wrote on conqueror
cream conqueror paper like this his lay
lady stuff his cream stuff with an
envelope and then I put my family crest
wax seal on it and I sprayed it with
them shonali go east so when she opened
a letter
she's got an airmail stamp from England
which makes it different
it's classy stationery she opens it and
this is sense this smell that she
remembers he go he stole yeah and it's
something she'll come back to because
this it's a sensory thing so I used that
bait without it's interesting that you
managed to get yourself through the door
using by finding out what these people
want what it is that they want and then
dangling that but how about when you
actually sit down with them have you got
a process obviously you you tend to
spend a lot of time corresponding back
and forth but when you eventually do get
face to face with them what you know
what is it that you're doing what is it
that you're saying or the way that
you're acting which is encouraging them
to give away more than they usually
should what what are the tricks of the
trade if you like is one thing that law
enforcement my friends in the FBI will
tell you in British peace you can't use
police can't use entrapment they can't
use they can't entrap a person
so but I can and and it's really about
making them feel comfortable with you
and you letting them know that although
that you're on their side but you know
you're not on their side and you are
chatting really and now that could be an
end game to it for me like with Arthur
Shawcross I wanted him to confess to her
murder of a little schoolboy called Jack
Blake and he called me you know the
language now but he was inches away from
me and and the guard said if he loses
the plot he could tell you head off
Christopher and we won't be in the room
now we show across he literally boiled
over he went white face went white sweat
pouring down his face when I mentioned
Jack Blake he told me not to ever
mention it otherwise he'd kill me and he
was but but I leaned forward and touched
his knee and I said come with your
girlfriend Clara's waiting outside and
she's asked me to be the best man at
your wedding Arthur and she's going to
go late if you don't tell me the whole
truth and then his face is in it there's
a TV interview on you will see it online
on the program and and and um he cracked
and the fury went and he he confessed
and it's a cat I saw sometimes they like
ball you and they will say something
bragging about Mike Michael roasted the
strangulation marks multiple marks
around the victims necks he got a kick
out of that he giggled and then I looked
at him straight in the face and said to
and Mike you know you're not a big
serial killer really are you I mean
seven or eight you're not Ted Bundy give
me a break
come on boy
just look stunned and then he went on to
try to describe more that way done you
know and and I got two cold cases I
teared up with him which were zoom not
too with Cornell University and a little
girl called Kimberly can be local
minimum crystal run so it depends how
you play I mean sometimes it's a serious
math because you're there to try to try
to bring closer to the next of kin and
you're the only point in the talk to it
so there is a heavy sword
[Music]
you